welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Boston my infinity saga rewatched
finally caught up with guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 for which writer director
James Gunn recently gave us YouTube
psychos a challenge ego Peter Quill's
biological father in search of a viable
celestial offspring did the dirty with
countless partners and made countless
duds the corpses of which he piled up
under his planet's surface in his cave
of shame it's a dark twist kind of hard
to look at yet Jamie Gunn tweeted yeah
there's done Easter eggs in among those
bones that no one's found yet basically
bringing that dinner bell for a bunch of
you to call your favorite grave digger
Indiana bones to find them we just
released an in-depth analysis of the
whole volume to film that you should
definitely go watch because there's so
much hidden meaning in every scene of
this film makes it even more valuable
now that movies like infinity war an end
game have come out here in this video
I'm just gonna recap what we found in
our little excavation and expand on it a
bit more because some of this stuff
could actually reveal where volume 3 is
going which James Gunn recently revealed
he's currently beyond a first draft for
let's break down this mother I am Groot
her with another tweet damn we called it
a corpse down before really what we
should call it is a skull search has a
throwback okay in total we get four
shots of this corpse heap first a wide
reveal composed largely of CGI it looks
like then to really make our flesh crawl
three close-ups of a practical set piece
getting closer and closer to the skull
so that when we come back to nebula our
mind goes well [ __ ] they're gonna be the
next goals on that pile floats during
the wide the heap itself wasn't really
designed for her eye to make out
specific skulls it's more about the bulk
of it all but to the sisters left there
is a slab with what looks like a Gungan
head from Star Wars is it Jar Jar Binks
who knows but rather than withering away
to a skull underneath it's just kind of
calcified like that dumbass is brain
already is and then slide over to the
right you can see what looks like the
head of stitch from Lilo & Stitch which
would make a bit of sense because that
guy pops up in a ton of different
realities I remember those trailers okay
these first two give us an important
clue to breakdown all this because they
are both Disney properties and Guardians
vol 2 is one of the first MCU films made
after Disney's total acquisition of
Marvel Studios allowing them to feature
Disney properties without having to
clear the references with the legal
departments of rival Studios that's why
age of Ultron had a weird Pinocchio
shout out and a man had it's weird it's
a small world shout out why is this
important well as a film nerd and as the
film nerd I know Jane
gun and his whole crew art when one has
a chance to sneak a bunch of alien skull
Easter eggs in your movie there are just
some obvious go twos you're gonna want
to put in there we're talking to Xena
more from alien predator heads that are
so iconic that their skull forms are
immediately recognizable the folks I
looked I don't think they're anywhere in
that heap there are some places where
you can kind of see an elongated cranium
similar to a xenomorph but it's either
too blurry or too small compared to
nearby humanoid skulls some times you
see some jawbone similar to the edge of
predator but none of it really matches
up right and I suspect this is because
at the time of guardians vol 2 s
production Alien and Predator were
franchises owned by 20th Century Fox and
clear obvious visual references to those
characters might have had to have been
cleared and paid for probably not that
worth it for a quick missable cameo only
found by like a bored obsessive YouTube
analysts unlike that aliens omage and
infinity war which was a plot point to
house spider-man and Iron Man save dr.
strange definitely worth it there
another example is the character of ego
the Living Planet was also at the time a
Fox property because it was associated
with Fantastic Four but Marvel
negotiated a special deal to use him in
their movie that involved a trade to Fox
to change the powers of negasonic
teenage warhead in Deadpool
floors now Disney owns all the Fox
properties anyway soon they're gonna and
everything so long as Disneyland reopen
soon home so okay the legal [ __ ] out of
the way back to the bones and the first
close-up right in the middle there's a
skull with a flat face which could be a
Chitauri shout out to wrestling discord
for this one we know James Gunn snuck a
Chitauri in the collectors vault in
volume 1 would make sense for another
one show up here but then the next two
close-ups show two angles of the same
part of the heap you tell by those long
yellowed fingers they're reference point
I was thinking and those fingers could
be the jointed digits of the facehugger
from aliens but like modified to give
extra fingers to avoid the rights issue
but in the last close up there is an
elongated skull similar to the korbinite
skeleton on Morag in volume 1 korbinite
is the race of beta ray bill a successor
to thor in the marvel comics statue of
him shows up on the grandmasters palace
since a car and thor ragnarok
right above those long fingers and
close-ups two and three there's this
beauty with a deep mouth in vertical
nostril slits which resembles the face
of the rancor from Return of the Jedi
shout out to a new master 68 for that
one you can see this one and others much
more clearly in a set photo that we're
actually able to track
down of this whole close-up heap
sometimes to find the answers to these
nerdy theories you gotta keep your brain
sharp and alert and when I want to see
stuff that I didn't know was there I pop
open a bang
thanks to bang energy for sponsoring
this video every can of bang is 16
ounces that's right there's no wimpy 12
ounce cans here it contains 300
milligrams of caffeine it's sugar-free
and has zero calories yet it tastes
great there's over 20 different flavors
to choose from one of those great
flavors is a rainbow unicorn because we
know it is fantasy canon that when
unicorns leap that's where rainbows come
from somehow they got it in a can and
that's what's doing in my mouth now
rainbow thanks Tina corns check out hang
on Instagram you can get 25 percent off
your order at bank - energy calm when
you use the code new rock stars 25 there
you can bike hands up bang energy
including their sweet tea and keto
coffee flavors you can also get clothing
fitness supplements all kinds of stuff
to be your best paying self thanks again
to bang energy for sponsoring this video
get 25% off at bang - energy gummies in
the code new rock stars 25 and follow
the Amanar bang on instagram at bang
energy to see you okay
this step photo has much better lighting
so what can we find in it yeah the rank
or similarity is much more apparent here
than the master also pointed to a curved
bone that looks a lot like the one Luke
used to race the rank course jaws open
so that he could escape right next to
this mini rancor there's this egg-shaped
cranium with big pronounced eyes that
looks a lot like a cartoon duck I was we
say how are the duck fight yeah he's
elsewhere in his universe so it isn't
him but he does come from a whole world
of duck world in so maybe it's another
one of them or maybe using that Disney
rule it could also be the skull of
Donald Duck or Daisy Duck beneath that
one is this creepy Lovecraftian looking
skulls very close round eyes and a lack
of a jaw bone gordon droid 'it's
chordbuddy it's kind of like me and numb
from the Star Wars films or maybe Davy
Jones from the Pirates of the Caribbean
series and to the right of this guy is a
huge skull without big nose and a
circular nob on its forehead
there's a guy Kyle on Twitter who
suggested that this one may be some
other nearby skulls could be those of
the annemun human-animal hybrids created
by the High Evolutionary Herbert Wyndham
whom the community of coordinates code
breakers have suggested could be the
mystery scientist who engineered rocket
watch the full breakdown for more
information on that but speaking of
rocket this heap appears to mix human
bones fantasy and scifi beast bones and
bones of typical earth animals some of
those rib cages and skulls look like
they
could belong to otters suggesting
perhaps an offspring from Rockets past
companion Lila whose name appeared as an
associate on his and our rap sheet in
volume 1 and my full movie analysis I
discussed how this film's final shot
being a close-up of rocket is meaningful
and James Gunn has indicated the rock is
a character he relates to the most and
volume 3 will focus on rocket and his
origin assuming the theories are right
and rocket was a product of the High
Evolutionary along with other hybrids
like Lila on half world maybe the high
evolutionary's purpose was to create
mates for ego after that sleazy
celestial had tapped out of all the
other known worlds and lost his Terran
offspring Peter quill to yondu I mean
what happened to Lila why did gonna
include her name in volume 1 must been
for a reason maybe Rockets past love
left him for some mammal from the stars
made out of pure light a creature that
rocket did not know at the time was the
same celestial held later fight in the
future in disguise trying to make a
viable offspring to help him canter up
the universe ego mated with lilah
produced an offspring but just like all
the other duds left that corpse in his
cave of shame and so rocket having
helped blow up egos brain that closure
might help rocket finally come to peace
now our rewatch did touch on one other
detail pertaining Rockets offspring when
ego explains how he made it with
countless partners one of them is the
same race as mantis and the Steve comps
some time ago Gunn posted that they used
stand-ins and that Stan and actress
posted claiming she played mantises
mother suggesting that mantis and
star-lord could be half siblings but
James Gunn debunked this theory he
confirmed that the race of egos partner
was the same as mantis but that doesn't
mean that partner was mantises mother I
doubt that will stop the weekly tweets
with people thinking they found a
bombshell clue that connects everything
I guess is more fun to be wrong ain't it
comment down below with the other skulls
you identify join our future infinity
saga watch along son discord by becoming
a patron at patreon.com slash new rock
stars follow me on instagram and twitter
ITA vas following rockstars and
subscribe but breakdowns everything you
love even if it's corpses you freak
[Music]